so
she we asked a lot of questions like so
what do you think about our great leader
you know that's a trick question
and you better come up with the right
answer because if you don't
i think he's a [ __ ] oh yeah then
somebody will be knocking on your door
you'll be asleep all of a sudden the
hood will come over your head you know
it'll be no joke yeah so
like like but in reality if you did say
something like that you'd be arrested
wow yes yes even if you're an american
more because you're in america you'll be
arrested
so so you could say so you can't say any
stuff like that did she try to like lead
you on at all to make you
make you try to like well what they do
is they they don't leave you on your
decision
but they lead you on in questions that
can potentially
get you into some [ __ ] i mean like lead
you on like try to like
tease you or like romantically people oh
no like you want to hang out later
whatever you'd be like hell yeah oh no
no no no she
she's very very serious okay she's she
was very very sick she wasn't
flirtatious
no no not not not at all i don't think
they have that in them
really i i don't think you remember
these people are so oppressed
i i don't even think she knows how to
funny because you know what flirting is
yeah they don't know they don't they
don't you can't watch movies and [ __ ]
right no you can't watch anything
outside of there
and and and you know um i
i wanted to see how brainwashed people
were because
you know in this day and age i couldn't
believe that people can
really be that brainwashed so i set up a
conversation with her
and i said hey um you guys like me a lot
right but why do you hate for why do you
hate
foreigners and the reason why i say you
guys i know you guys like i see you guys
like me a lot
was to defuse any possible
uh idea that she would think that i'm
trying to
start some [ __ ] right so so i was like
yeah
i know you guys like me a lot but why
you guys hate wasn't it she said well
we don't hate westerners we just don't
want western
we we don't want the western influence
in our country so i said okay
i said okay i can understand sometime
you know us westerners we mess things up
and i go and say now mind you what i'm
doing now
is actually very dangerous it's
extremely dangerous
i could be in a lot of [ __ ] trouble
so i go to i go
but you know that every country in the
world
needs uh the the help and influence of
other countries
to to to to you know succeed
and and and to flourish and she goes
well that's not true
in in our great country everything was
done by our great
leader with zero western influence and
drew our great leader through our great
country blah blah blah
i said well your great leader
has some western influence so right now
i'm i'm in i'm i'm i'm i'm just touching
the tip of the [ __ ] right now
so i'm like you know you're western
leaders from what's the influence and
she goes
that's not true everything through
north korea by north korea blah blah
blah and i said okay
what about basketball she said
basketball was created in north korea by
a great leader
and i was like whoa so i wanted to get
deeper
i wanted to get deeper so i didn't
really argue with her in that
so i said okay right you didn't want if
you would have argued with her it would
have been another thing
so i said okay i said
do you know that your great leader
studied outside of north korea
now i don't know what the hell i was
thinking of when i when i was saying
this
but this could get you arrested is that
true yeah
i didn't even know that switzerland yeah
but this that's why he speaks english
perfect english
this could get you arrested and and i
and she says
that's not true i said that it's true i
said everyone knows it the whole world
knows it and then sometimes you forget
what your purpose is
when you're in these conversations and
you start to take it personally so at
this point i was thinking personally
because i'm like
you're [ __ ] now you're like kind of
like speaking from the heart yeah i'm
like you're dumb as hell and you you're
not
listen know it yeah and so now i'm
forgetting what the purpose is and i'm
starting to get a little like
no everyone in the world knows this this
is a fact
then she starts to get a little upset
and she goes
this is not true he's never left
this and then i said oh my god you know
what i'm so sorry it was the cuban
president my bad
got out of that [ __ ] real fast that
could have turned out
it could have turned real bad for me
like and luckily i caught myself
herself in the middle in the middle of
it because i she was getting upset and
all she needs to do is just
go back and report and then you you know
you get 15 years
and it's corrupting the minds of
citizens that's a charge
like i've studied everything about north
korea before i went there so
i knew corrupting the minds of the
citizens yeah as a charge
yes 15 years it will put you 15 years in
a hard labor camp 15 so that's why
you're not allowed to bring books in
north korea
you're not allowed to bring music
nothing of the western world
that can potentially get into hands of
north koreans
should you bring yeah because
that's corrupting the mind of citizens
when you first got there how long did
they keep your phone and your computer
for
that was pretty quick they it was it was
at the airport
okay i got it right back i don't know
what they did to it i um maybe they went
through it and
i put some sort of [ __ ] tracking [ __ ]
i don't know what they did maybe mike's
i don't know
so i have no idea but but but they gave
it back to me so i had the phone
but regardless it's useless once it's
there because you don't have any service
zero zero the only one time i was able
to get service was
i bumped into a chinese guy who couldn't
even speak english
that much but he recognized me from my
hair
from you see my hairstyles are crazy
yeah so he recognizes dennis rodman
yeah he reckoned me from the chinese tv
so
he tried to talk to me and and i i don't
understand chinese but i
kind of get the idea that he recognized
me and i saw he had a phone
and his phone was working with internet
and everything
so then i figured it out chinese
citizens
are allowed to have internet and phone
service because
china has an agreement with north korea
do they really yeah
so oh so remember when america was
beefing america kept saying to china
like yo
call me a guy because because of that
china has an agreement with
with them so chinese citizens get to
have cell phone service so
i i i talked to this guy say hey hey
listen
um in english but he can't speak but
i say what i want to do i want to use
his phone so that i could
get internet from his phone onto my
phone real quickly
and and and he let me do it i took his
phone his iphone of course and i know
how to set it to it
and so i got to use the internet for
like maybe like two minutes because i
don't get arrested so
i just wanted to check in emails real
quick yeah and for two minutes i got to
use this phone
but yeah um for like for me it's nothing
zero so that that that that's why i say
it's the most dangerous place
yeah because anything can happen to you
it people don't realize it's
look look what happened to the american
kid that went there that the college
student went there and came back and
died here
you hear about that no what are you
talking about oh yeah yeah so a few
years ago
a college student went to north korea on
some trip i don't know
and um he tried to steal a propaganda
poster
which is the dumbest thing you could
ever do if you researched
anything about north korea you would
know they are watching you
every second yeah and then he and they
caught him and they arrested him
and and i don't know what they did to
him like they said i didn't do anything
to him but i don't believe it
he came in and died how did he die they
said
that he had botulism or whatever some
virus or some
some i don't know something sick and
just died i don't believe that
i i don't believe it so he came up they
sent him back they sent him back here
and he died here
yeah so so it's it's uh it's really
really really a serious place like you
can't mess around
and and and you know i've learned from
traveling
you know you just got to respect the
[ __ ] that goes on in other people's
countries
because it can turn really bad for you
and especially if you're an american
because you're the person that they want
to make an example of
is i mean you're the one that they want
to
put on that on that tv for propaganda
look at this american who did this to
our country
you know so so you never want to be that
guy no
don't be that guy yes so so once i
started figuring out
she was getting upset i just changed it
real quick and and that was it
i never talked about it again i never
talked about it again